comandante antonio give me your orders
your legs at the foot of the letter you who
I fought for big and young with a
Fight icon represents your body going to
rest but your ideals go to
to flourish
today for you I will fight damn government
repressor you have and when we see that
some colleagues start coming out
they were inside the church and they
they hear some detonations inside the
church but weapon detonations of
fire when I see commander that was
next to me he puts his hand to his chest and
says wounded wounded wounded and reaches
fall face down because I think I saw it
die there you do not want to see people anymore
they feel like the government is suffocating
there is no need of the world they told me
it was not the last time
do it for your son
and for my son I do it for him is that
I am fighting
the rice went away
the children that would return
approximately two years of the child
for him only killing is happy that
just repressing leaves attentive hitting
children because it was a child that had
saved in our region
the same offspring mired by that my
brother wanted to do someone in the
life wanted to fight
I came to understand that as a child
I